there are plenty of ways you can get
yourself banned in a game cheating
obviously boosting even unsportsmanlike
conduct can get you the hammer but we
may have just seen the most bizarre
reason yet playing too
[Music]
much listen we've all had our fair share
of those nights spent gaming into the
Wii hours for some of us maybe more
often than we'd like to admit but other
than sleep deprivation and maybe the
scolding from a loved one we never
expected any real consequences
especially none in game well as it turns
out there could be last Wednesday a
former nacs pro sluggy got a 24-hour
face it ban for guess what playing too
much that's right folks after playing 78
pugs over the course of a 72-hour binge
sluggy was banned now originally sluggy
thought he was going to get banned for
failing to start a match because his
game game kept crashing but after trying
to work things out with face at support
sluggy was finally given that 24-hour
ban and for a reason they simply said go
to sleep really that is that is an
actual ban you're telling me they this
this is the reason despite a third party
taking away slug's god-given right to
play CS to his heart's content the
reaction online was almost entirely on
face its side replies like reality check
banned and you've become a legal
liability were just some of the
responses in favor of faet decision
posting aside a lot of people seemed
actually genuine about this with some
going so far as to say that facet might
have a responsibility to step in at
times like this but do they from Death
stranding to Warframe to the OG We Touch
grass message games have often suggested
players take a break from playing now
from what I can gather games don't
actually have a legal responsibility to
tell you to take a break so it's more
out of Goodwill and for good reason as
linked to in the other articles on this
story gaming for extended periods of
time has a lot of health concerns that
go Way Beyond just simple iin similar to
the years of concerns we saw over
sitting too long during office jobs one
of the most common side effects in these
more Extreme Gaming cases is a blood
clot that can often result in death in
2011 a 20-year-old man died after
consecutive 12-hour sessions of Halo the
next year a teen died after binging
Diablo I for over 40 hours just a few
years ago we saw it happen again and I
haven't even brought up World of
Warcraft in these cases yet now dying
from a blood clot is pretty much worst
case scenario but there are plenty of
other much more common side effects that
come from a lack of sleep when you game
too much point is there's plenty of
legitimate concerns and my guess is that
games send out little messages like this
as a PR move to cover themselves from
parental backlash now obviously sluggy
could still play CS if he wanted to a
face IT band doesn't equate a vac band
but it still sets a very interesting in
president my assumption is that an admin
saw his stream and decided to do what
was best for the guy but I can't help
but wonder if it wasn't just the right
call but one that should be the rule
people often point to countries like
China for their Draconian rules on
internet usage in gaming but in these
very extreme situations should
developers step in but what's the
threshold 12 hours 24 hours too many
days in a row what about people doing
subathon or trying to break records
where do you draw the line my guess is
that despite the reaction to sluggy most
Gamers would be vehemently against any
policing like this it also might not
even be possible I'm not exactly sure
what the rules are on Banning someone
from playing something that they paid
for even if it is for their own good but
if we treat gaming addiction like a real
addiction as some do sometimes
intervention is the best way to start
helping now obviously not everyone in
these situations is dealing with
something as severe as an addiction but
let me know what you guys think did fa
it make the right call here and should
games ever limit how much you can play
even if it can save your life but I also
like my my brothers used make fun of me
because I would like like when I would
ask to use the computer back when we
just had a computer they'd make fun of
me because like every 20 minutes they'd
come down I'd be playing a different
game I'd like play a game for 20 minutes
and be like okay now I want to play this
game and I'd play but it was because
they didn't let me play that much so I
needed to like try all of them